qui a le moins de répartie par exemple
mathieu pour vous un tour de table oui à
le moindre est parti et parce que le
losc
je dirais isabelle il s'appelle sais
vraiment pas ah oui ça me passionne
n'était pas drôle tout afin qu'ils
soient toujours passer à côté de moi en
toi seulement
valérie à babaji ah oui on le voit aux
véhicules mais le plus le plus le plus
dur est parti un bâtiment n'a pas mal et
pour vous tout va comme ça qui m'a
poussé moi oui
parce qu'il m'aimait plus de la
catégorie artiste est pas chroniqueur
côté sort de ma chambre était pas mon
père ouais vert si j'avais été ton père
te rappelle cette tête de dégénérer en
un peu de respect pour les gens qui
bossent sa mère s'il te plaît
rouge pardon mais j'ai l'impression que
tu te masturbes un peu n'importe comment
attends je vais te montrer
les mines
qu'est-ce que vous avez vous avez mis
non ah non pardon non j'étais très gêné
parce qu'en fait les phrases de ma fille
elles sont à la fois très très drôle
mais à la fois très très mal éteinte
hier son plateau où je sens quand même
si froid quand même
y en a des jolies bah oui à l'essai
malaisie mais pas dans ce bouquin
[Rires]
taxi coop peuple le plus doré
participants c'est mathieu lindon et le
moins assez moi
c'est vrai c'est vrai en fait je panique
q bat justement y aura le cul du cul
dans un haras et j'aurai une surprise
pour vous j'ai eu mes surprises avec
vous hier soir non mais on donnera
demain ah oui voilà le fpi c'est comme
si les cosmétiques
mais c'est ça le problème est la
répartie quoi c'est ça
chaque fois la répartie s'il va repartir
sur tout ça fiona le plus de
répartissent dire et géraldine ce
qu'elle est elle répond de manière
vraiment très sobre mais à chaque fois
c'est dans sa bulle et le moindre est
parti vas-y en
est ce qu'on peut et est ce qu'on peut
est-ce que ça se travaille la répartir
oui bien sûr non seulement il suffit de
répondre tout le temps n'importe quoi
n'importe qui peu après on sélectionne
un peu ce qu'on peut faire initiée
voilà j'ai fait ce bouquin pour ça non
c'est un cours d'eau répartis on veut
pas donner un coup comme ça verbalement
il faut que les gens craignent de cette
gymnastique et faut qu'ils s'imprègnent
de ça il ya tout les alors des masques à
des phrases super relou pas un petit
collège en réalité il ya des phrases sûr
je suis pas je trouve une phrase drôles
ou genre à être non plus les fonds le
même pour un pour les hommes mais ça
c'est 508 urémique shu
pourquoi j'ai une des deux femmes oui à
la masse
c'est pas mal ouais c'est mieux que moi
[Applaudissements]
oh
pour adé tout petit je commence à semer
devant la ta mère
dans mon livre
je ne laisserai pas passer des bressans
que vous avez et toi c'est vrai qu'on a
lors de mon atelier